[Música]
inicialmente gostaria de mostrar algumas
fotos que eu sou isso nem para vocês
hoje vocês saberiam dizer quem são essas
pessoas
poderia ser por exemplo uma chácara que
perto de brasília né
talvez poderia ser lago lago norte
esses são os cidadãos mas são um tipo
especial de cidadãos e cidadãs de
fronteira é uma fronteira muito especial
para mim porque é uma fronteira na qual
eu cresci lá eu mantenho relações
pessoais inclusive minha família
agora imaginem se ainda hoje consideram
o estado de minha família mora roraima
tão longínquo e imagine naquela época e
que na época em que eu cresci que nos
anos 90 para minha parte de uma tríplice
fronteira junto com a guiana inglesa a
venezuela e logicamente brasil
essas são algumas das fotos da minha
infância
elas inclusive representam locais que
estão localizados na fronteira é
especificamente são as fronteiras com a
goiânia com a guiana inglesa
como vocês podem ver pelas fotos
há um elemento comum em todas elas que a
água e é sobre isso que eu queria me de
ter um pouco mais agora
roraima é parte da chamada ilha das
goianas
ela compartilha com esses dois
territórios a guiana ea venezuela que
seria chamado de uma ilha até porque são
dois países que têm entrado no promar no
entanto sendo uma ilha né
sendo parte de uma idéia ela não está
necessariamente isolado e é sobre isso
que eu queria me de ter mais um pouco
agora no entanto se de um lado vemos que
realmente não é uma área isolada então
por onde que se direciona essas
oportunidades
algumas dessas oportunidades por exemplo
se direciona para o lado da venezuela
com a comunidade andina de nações
o mesmo do lado do mercosul aqui no
brasil ou até mesmo por caricom
comunidade do caribe
do lado das guianas
se de um lado as oportunidades não se
consolidaram
algumas tendências que já verificamos
como por exemplo a questão migratória
como vários dos estados de fronteira e
roraima também tem vários grupos que
passam por lá
esses que estão mostrando a questão
nicaragüenses mas há também haitianos a
cubanos argentinos que são nossos
vizinhos próximos
há também colombianos além desses há
outros que vêm do além mar como por
exemplo pessoas deve trégua da gâmbia
são vários grupos que passam por lá
novamente são os mares que estão nos
conectamos são as águas que estão
transportando essas pessoas
atualmente o que vemos a miriam a
ligação principalmente do grupo de
venezuelanos devido a uma grave com uma
grave crise de governabilidade na
venezuela têm migrado para a região
principalmente em busca de serviços de
saúde trabalho e até e atendimento nas
mais diversas áreas sociais
além desses grupos de imigrantes nós
temos também né populações mais
tradicionais populações autóctones da
região e há o estado é grande parte da
população indígena são quase dez grupos
que existem a nós temos ingaricós uso e
me aturar isso os mais ricos neco
reconhecidos internacionalmente como se
a nomes
uai entre tantos outros no entanto sendo
um estado de fronteira estando próxima
né outros países também com graves
problemas sociais roraima no time
enfrenta também de problemas alguns
deles por exemplo é a questão do
desemprego da inserção produtiva que
dificultam a vida na região
no entanto há também outras
oportunidades em outras áreas a exemplo
principalmente dos contatos que tem sido
têm sido estabelecidos com os jovens do
outro lado da fronteira e que gostam de
esportes principalmente que gosta de
trocas culturais são essas trocas então
que dinamiza relação fronteiriça
no entanto ainda que a gente veja essa
integração é a também né
graves problemas que a gente vê também
em outras partes do mundo a exemplo da
da europa e é onde se estabeleceram
muitas guerras é por sorte nós não temos
isso aqui ainda assim acho que todas
elas são espaço que abriga uma
multiculturalidade é eu poderia dizer
que existem existem povos indígenas mais
do que um povo indígena além dos povos
indígenas nós temos os migrantes nós
temos a própria população que lá que lá
reside
é o fim eu queria falar que é esses
mares nessas pessoas que que vieram pra
que estão chegando em boa vista que
estão chegando em horário que estão
chegando nas nossas fronteiras
elas vieram de mares e marias distantes
muitas delas vieram de locais que e
agora passarão a integrar esse mosaico
que é um é que a obstrução social
brasileira é e assim começo é e assim
como essas pessoas que vêm de mais
longíquos são esses mares que tem
conectado cada vez mais essas populações
a nós é isso
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]